[Music]
welcome
my name is kate hertwick i'm the
bioinformatics training manager at fred
hutchinson cancer research center in
seattle washington
career focus is helping scientists learn
the coding and data skills they need
to apply cutting-edge computational
methods and accelerate the rate of
science
i'm excited to tell you about one of the
best parts of my job
helping researchers unlock the mindset
and tools
that help them make the most of their
data and get more work done
in less time here's how the general
process of teaching someone
are usually happens i work for a
biomedical research center
with a huge breadth of research topics
but everyone wants to make figures for
publication
my community loves r especially tidy
verse
because it makes sense to them to be
able to achieve those goals
in my introductory art class i start by
teaching some general skills in data
manipulation
and filtering my participants learn to
create
elegant effective data visualizations
that help them explore their data after
a few hours bent over their keyboards
i can see the slowly dawning realization
in their eyes
with the power unlocked by coding i will
surely obtain a statistically
significant result
supporting my insightful hypothesis
yielding fame and glory
but more importantly a paper in nature
or science as well as future grant
funding
in case you're not a scientist and this
doesn't resonate with you
let's think about it from a layperson's
uh well
lay dogs perspective for scientists
unlocking the power of coding is like
when we're dogs getting a one-way ticket
to the dog park
complete with all of our favorite toys
and lots of interesting things to sniff
that moment when the dog realizes
the dog park is near is like that moment
when an important concept about data or
computational work
clicks for someone learning r and they
see a
world of opportunity open up for them
unfortunately all too often
when the time comes to apply their
skills to their own data
they're confronted with a console that
looks more like this
these red error messages are sometimes
scary often confusing
and always frustrating the prevalent
feeling they experience is
disappointment
tinged with a touch of how am i supposed
to achieve fame and glory when i can't
even get r
to acknowledge my data exists
that crushing defeat in the face of such
promise
is also something a dog can relate to
it's the equivalent of jumping in the
car
thinking we're heading to the dog park
we can almost feel the breeze
taste the rubber ball in our mouth and
smell the grass
instead ending up at the vet this
is exactly the opposite of what we
wanted
it's disappointing and demoralizing so
much so that we don't want to get in the
car again
even if we might end up at the dog park
eventually someday
so how do we jump over this barrier
restoring a belief
that we can achieve those lofty goals
when i accepted my current position to
develop and implement a training program
in reproducible computational methods
two and a half years ago
i thought the most important part of my
job would be time spent in a classroom
i had spent the previous four years
teaching computational skills to
students at the university level
and after an entire career in academia
i thought that the highest impact i
could have at a research center
would involve teaching formally
structured short courses
during my career i've had the privilege
of personally teaching hundreds of
people to code in r
especially in my last few years focusing
on adult learners
outside of formal university courses
i've learned a lot about what it takes
to help people succeed
in learning r and that success is not
solely reliant
on formal short courses now i define
success as whether people continue to
work with r
after leaving my classroom or at least
if they gain some general
literacy and data and computing skills
so they can work more effectively with
computational staff
given the breadth of research topics
members of my community pursue
i am faced with the monumental task of
helping people apply
our skills to many different types of
data and research questions
the question i then continually ask
myself as i prepare to
deliver training materials is this what
prevents people from using these tools
after they've learned them let's take a
quick tour of the process of gaining
expertise and think about what this
looks like with coding
regardless of the prior education
someone possesses in a different field
i consider a person who has no prior
experience learning to code in
our a novice in my community
that means they probably don't have any
experience coding
in a different language and probably
also don't know much about how to
structure and store their data
effectively
i integrate general concepts and coding
and data management
into my intro r course and focus on
directly applicable skills like those
i showed in code earlier by the time
someone has completed my introductory
art class
i like to think that they're no longer a
novice
since they have now transitioned to
competent
a practitioner probably doesn't know if
the way that they code represents the
most
elegant or efficient solution to a
problem
but they get the job done i consider
expert level coders to be people who are
writing code that make it easy for other
people to use it
they encapsulate their projects in fully
documented r
packages and try to apply best practices
in coding
to make it robust and reproducible
to be clear i'm less concerned about
formally categorizing people into these
groups
i think more about how to help people
follow the arrows to the right
in practice most people i encounter are
practitioners of some type
most often interested in getting the
immediate job done regardless this model
is a really useful way to think about a
few key questions
what do people need to learn and how are
they most likely to learn these things
we're going to investigate these
questions by visiting a few colleagues
of mine who generally represent each of
these categories
please meet ash ash is
trained in software engineering and
currently works
in data management and software
development in a research lab
writing software for scientists to use
for research purposes
ash is writing a package named borker
borker creates maps indicating density
of dogs being walked in certain areas of
a city at certain times
ash hopes that borker will be used for
both public dog
health tracking as well as integration
with the dog social media network
snoot work however ash hasn't worked
much with maps lately
and ash needs to know the best
approaches and are to achieve their
goals
what ash does is go and asks on twitter
and some local slack communities for
their recommendations
they are able to narrow down the options
available
based on what they and their friends
understand about the project
requirements
ash goes ahead and references the
relevant documentation for each option
and given their breadth of knowledge ash
can quickly identify the relevant
functions and how to connect them
together
to implement mapping in the context of
borker
one of ash's colleagues is named avery
avery's a graduate student
with some formal coursework in data
science but is still learning the best
methods for optimizing workflows in
r avery is developing documentation
for a group of summer interns and wants
to streamline the process
of creating projects with them avery
goes and asks ash
who recommends the package use this
avery's really excited goes and takes a
look at the main documentation page
and is really intimidated they
haven't worked with a package like this
before and they also haven't worked much
with git
or github which is one of the really
awesome features
involved in use this they especially
aren't comfortable
in their ability to use this package and
help other people use the tool as well
so avery comes to my office hours and
asks for help
i point them towards a project from our
colleagues lab
that actually applies use this
this particular project is a template
that includes working with github
starting an analysis and explaining
why their particular approach works for
data analysis
projects the explanation avery needed
didn't just include the code to run but
an example
of how all the pieces would fit together
in a final project
avery's really excited about this
breakthrough and uses the package to
support their summer intern
quinn quinn is an undergraduate in
biology
who has recently started learning
computational methods
quinn thought my intro r class was quite
intuitive
and is eager to apply their skills to
their summer project
however they ended up encountering the
same problem i showed at the beginning
of this talk
errors associated with read underscore
csv
now quinn knows how to use the help
function
to share information about it
and then they encounter what is in my
opinion one of the great contradictions
of computing
the simpler a function seems the more
complicated the help documentation
appears
especially to someone new to coding
quinn's reaction is similar to the
general response i get from a novice
learner's first glance at this help
documentation
a bit of abject horror thinking what
have i done
however quinn goes and talks to avery
who helps them think about the basics of
our coding
the structure of their data and how
their project is organized
ultimately helping them understand how
to piece together that information
to import their data
these of course are the problems with
which we all
grapple on a nearly daily basis how do
we prioritize how to exert our energy
especially when we have different goals
with competing interests
and it's not clear whether or not the
effort we're exerting is going to make
a huge difference in the long run these
questions
include things like do i write a
vignette or add a new feature to the
package i'm developing
do i keep trying to get this function to
work for my analysis
or do i give up and try something else
how do i even find the help i need
to address this key issue as it turns
out
even small differences in how support
materials are developed
can make the difference between someone
struggling and wrestling with
implementing a new approach
or being able to take the ball and run
with it
this is because in my experience
learning specific
technical skills is easy
however once you've learned how a
technical skill generally operates
being able to apply that to your own
problem
is much more difficult the usefulness of
training and documentation
depends on both what information is
provided
and how it's delivered
now that we have an idea of the problem
we face how do we actually meet these
needs
so far i've made some generally vague
references to training materials and
documentation
i think it's worth highlighting what
some of these options include
and if you'd like more information on
detailed descriptions of types of
materials
head over to the resources i've included
in rstudio's collection of conference
materials
first manuals we have a baseline
expectation in the r community that a
standardized user manual
documenting features of a package is
included
this particular documentation provides
basic information like how does a
function work
and what options are available for
working with the function
in my experience manuals are most useful
for
expert users or people who have some
familiarity
with how the particular type of function
can work
another type of material is vignettes
vignettes answer questions like how do
functions work together to answer
general questions
these tend to be more like demos or
tutorials for implementing code
which ends up making them much more
accessible for a broad variety of users
a third type of support material are
example projects or code
these demonstrate what an applicable
authentic
project incorporating a tool looks like
and these end up being very crucial
especially for practitioners
fourth formally structured in-depth
short courses
are generally in highest demand for
novices and often something that most
people are familiar with
they would like someone to tell them
what the answers are
now each of these different approaches
requires a different amount of effort
to both find if you're wanting to learn
from it or
develop if you are creating it and
sometimes these resources do blend
together
they're also generally supplemented by
conversations with colleagues
which i've found is one of the most
valuable ways to fill in knowledge gaps
now that we've considered how types of
support vary based on levels of
expertise
let's return to ash ash is excited that
their package
is nearing completion so they share the
manual with avery and quinn
avery has trouble understanding how some
of the borker functions work
but learns a lot in the process of
trying to figure it out
quinn doesn't understand any of it
including
that ash actually wrote the package
and then quinn tries to google it to
find more information
they come across search results for a
chinese death metal band by the same
name
and ash ultimately regrets not googling
the name before deciding on it for their
package
at this point ash has a choice continue
the package development to
integrate with snoot work or make it
clearer what the package is doing right
now
ash decides to ask avery to collaborate
on explaining
how functions fit together more clearly
in a vignette
they are supported by another of ash's
colleagues who have developed
some code using borker which ash is
happy to reference in the documentation
for the package
quinn keeps attending meetings and
learns a lot about the process of code
collaboration
and eventually even clarifies a few
instructions in the manual
this story from my colleagues is one
example of the process
of developing documentation what does it
mean in broader practice though
there are countless online classes
tutorials demos and other resources
that can help you learn r these are
approaches that walk us through the
process
of some coding tasks essentially leading
you by a leash
given that availability why do people
keep coming into my classroom
what i've learned really makes or breaks
progression to higher levels of
expertise
is access to information that helps fill
in the biggest gaps in our knowledge
my job as a trainer is to provide
guidance that fills in those gaps
which allows learners to keep moving in
the same direction
but without a leash so that they have
guidance
but more importantly autonomy
so while i'm developing support
materials i consider
identifying what knowledge is assumed
in the materials i'm developing as well
as collecting
curated examples of code that apply
methods commonly
desired in my community in fact one of
the most effective things we can do
is share high quality training materials
with the people for whom they are most
suited
the ecosystem of tools available in our
community
really reflects the interests of the
people comprising that community
with so many tools to maintain and
develop is it worth
developing and maintaining support
materials too
well we share our code so other people
can benefit from our hard work
and to increase the impact of our
efforts
if sharing our code results in a
multiplier effect for our effort
then making it easier for people to use
the code
multiplies it yet again at a time when
disparities in the world
feel more stark than ever access to
information makes a huge difference in
promoting
equity for developing these skills
these values are why we support open
science projects
and that means considering how even our
small actions
can continue to uphold these values
in many cases we don't even have to
create these materials ourselves
knowing what resources exist and helping
raise their visibility
can have a huge impact too
regardless of what level of expertise
you think best describes you
please consider the following for those
of us beginning to code in
r it's likely we'll encounter a piece of
documentation
we don't understand that's okay
and it's not our fault that information
probably isn't written to be accessible
for people with our type of expertise
there's almost certainly a better
resource out there or materials that can
help us bridge that gap
for those of us who are practitioners
worrying that
even if our code works it just isn't
good enough
it's okay every expert coder has been
where we are now
there's also no requirement that we keep
learning more advanced skills
but the community is here to help us and
it'll probably be very satisfying to
learn
finally those of us who are experts
developing our packages
unsure how to make the information
accessible to a broad audience
it's okay this is a great opportunity
for us to collaborate
with someone with a different type of
expertise
these relationships can help us share
our tools
more broadly while supporting other
community members in advancing their own
skills
for all of us struggling to communicate
with people who possess
different knowledge and skills remember
this is something
everyone confronts given that we're all
continually learning things
and yes also forgetting things
periodically
our own knowledge and that of those
around us is constantly changing too
making for a sometimes rapidly moving
target
one of the best things we can do for
each other is understand that we can't
expect a resource to be one size fits
all
and that helping someone else learn is a
way of supporting the entire community
as well as yourself in the future i
learned about the basic framework of
levels of expertise from the carpentries
this nonprofit group teaches
reproducible data and computing skills
including r to communities worldwide
and have a number of resources related
to training diverse audiences and
technical skills
my current work at fred hutch builds on
methods and materials from the
carpentries
i've adapted their workshop content to
directly apply to the research community
i serve
we otherwise apply the concepts i've
discussed here to training
and community development i'm also proud
to be advising
meredith a group focused on a different
type of targeted community development
supporting educational practices for
spanish-speaking communities
and this includes teaching technical
skills
each of these groups facilitate training
for diverse audiences
and demonstrate how even small changes
can mean a lot
for individual learners in the r
community
if you'd like more information about the
ideas i've mentioned here
check out the resources i've included in
our studio's collection of conference
materials
if you'd like to talk about
computational training and customizing
our resources
follow me on twitter i can also
recommend my twitter account if you'd
like to see pictures of my favorite
co-worker
loki he wouldn't consider himself to be
even a novice
r coder but he does listen very intently
to all of my thoughts about training
and community building thanks for
watching
and for helping support a bigger more
inclusive
global r community
you